[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeombroselas es
un placer saludarles en el programa de
hoy hablamos de un caso que ha afectado
gravemente a esta institución al
parlamento europeo un supuesto caso de
corrupción en que Qatar y Marruecos
habrían pagado supuestamente cuantiosas
sumas de dinero a miembros de la
eurocámara para tratar de influir en las
políticas europeas que afectaran a estos
países antes de pasar al debate veamos
un repaso a los puntos clave de esta
investigación
en diciembre de 2022 la policía belga
destapó uno de los mayores casos de
corrupción de la historia del parlamento
europeo una trama en la que
supuestamente
Qatar pagó cuantiosas sumas de dinero a
trabajadores y asesores de la
institución también a organizaciones que
luchan a favor de los Derechos Humanos
para influir a su favor en las
decisiones europeas de momento hay
cuatro personas detenidas entre ellas la
ex vicepresidenta de la eurocámara la
griega iba caíli también están en
prisión su pareja ex asesor de un
eurodiputado y dos miembros de dos
conocidas ongs
la justicia belga ya solicitó que se le
retire la inmunidad a otros dos
eurodiputados según las pesquisas el
supuesto líder de la red de sobornos fue
Antonio panzeri un antiguo eurodiputado
y presidente de la organización no
gubernamental Fight impronity las
últimas investigaciones también
encontraron Que Marruecos formaría parte
de la trama y que habría tratado de
influ miembros de la eurocámara mientras
la presidenta del parlamento europeo
Roberta metzola avanzó que se hará un
plan de reforma para mejorar la
transparencia de la institución Y
promete que no habrá impunidad
y para hablar de este caso ya bautizado
como
qatargate Contamos con el eurodiputado
del grupo social demócrata Juan Fernando
López Aguilar bienvenido Muchísimas
gracias encantado de estar con ustedes y
con la eurodiputada del grupo renovar
Europa Maite pagaza bienvenida Maite
Bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación muchas gracias a los dos este
supuesto caso de corrupción se ha vivido
como un auténtico choque las
instituciones europeas en la
investigación se apunta acatar también a
Marruecos me gustaría preguntaros dos
cuestiones alguna vez temieron que un
caso así podría haber afectado a este
parlamento y creen que podría ser
incluso la punta hice ver de un caso
mucho más grave Juan Fernando la
corrupción puede producirse en
circunstancia en cualquier momento y hay
que estar siempre muy prevenido y muy
alerta pero usted lo descrito bien el
impacto ha sido un shock por tanto lo
primero
consternación sorpresa perplejidad
asombro en segundo lugar
consternación y
debo decirlo ir a desatada un cabreo
Monumental un enfado sideral por parte
del conjunto del parlamento europeo y
finalmente una respuesta una respuesta
que ha sido básicamente unitaria y
además inmediata de modo que primero se
destituyó a la vicepresidenta encausada
a expensas de que se complete la
investigación judicial Y en segundo
lugar se adoptó una resolución muy
potente para intentar reforzar todos los
controles preventivos y represivos
contra cualquier forma de corrupción
pero quiero decir que este caso de
corrupción no
concierne al parlamento europeo ni
contamina el parlamento europeo son
responsabilidades individualmente
contraídas por las personas que están
siendo investigadas a expensas de que se
complete la investigación judicial en el
sistema judicial penal belga con toda la
cooperación del parlamento europeo pero
debo cumplir con mi obligación
defendiendo la honorabilidad y la
credibilidad del parlamento europeo como
institución directamente lectiva que
representa el conjunto de la ciudadanía
europea
bueno efectivamente el shock lo hemos
sufrido todos porque nadie tiende a
pensar que su vecino de escaño devoto
puede llegar a ser una persona corrupta
y hay una cuestión y es que en el
parlamento tenemos mucha libertad los
diputados tenemos nuestra propia oficina
y ahí somos muchos y hay muchas
comisiones entonces uno tiende a confiar
de la misma manera que hace su trabajo y
confía en su equipo Pues tiende a
confiar en que los demás estarán
haciendo las cosas correctamente ha sido
un mazazo pero la resolución que
aprobamos en el plenario anterior es una
resolución extraordinaria O sea sí que
hemos reaccionado muy rápidamente hemos
reaccionado Unidos no nos hemos tirado
los trastos a la cabeza acusando a uno
otro grupo político hemos entendido que
era un tema individual y si hacemos lo
que aparece en la hoja de ruta que
describe la resolución yo creo que
brindaremos mucho o en la manera de lo
posible tanto la entrada de los
corruptores
vía el registro de transparencia lobbies
diarios etcétera como los propios grupos
de amistad como incluso la manera de
trabajar en las delegaciones aquellos
que suelen intervenir en ellas yo creo
que vamos a reaccionar bien pero sí
la consternación ha sido terrible o sea
íbamos a casa
que no sabíamos Cómo contárselo a la
familia de la tristeza que teníamos
justamente sobre estos grupos de amistad
la presidenta de la del parlamento
europeo Roberta me he hecho la asegurado
que va a prohibir estos grupos de
amistad estos grupos en que había entre
eurodiputados con países
ha sido el parlamento europeo demasiado
ingenuo permitiendo este tipo de
prácticas Maite yo creo que sí
sinceramente yo no sabía que existían me
enteré
a raíz de la noticia Mire un poquito en
las redes sociales y encontré que había
algunos otros países Por cierto no de
los
en fin no de los más ortodoxos que
También tenían este tipo de práctica con
respecto a acatar por ejemplo o con
respecto a emiratos Unidos etcétera y yo
creo que esto nos tiene que poner en
guardia o sea en adelante cualquier cosa
que tenga que ver con países que pueden
ser de alto riesgo
o dudoso riesgo que comisión de
desinformación estamos trabajando
aquellos países que utilizan la
captación de élites para aprovecharse y
tener un impacto geopolítico en contra
de nuestros intereses todas estas cosas
las tenemos que ver en todas las
comisiones que sean necesarios en la de
asuntos constitucionales por si hay que
cambiar el registro de transparencia y
también en desinformación o en otras que
sea necesario o sea creo que tenemos que
ajustar los tornillos a los instrumentos
para para funcionar mejor Juan Fernando
ha pecado de ingenuo El parlamento
europeo es necesario explicar a quienes
nos escuchan que el parlamento europeo
se distingue por ser la única
institución directamente lectiva y
legitimada por el voto es el único
parlamento
democráticamente electo
supranacional
y legislativo del mundo y esto me
importa subrayarlo porque este
parlamento es un parlamento legislador
aquí estamos haciendo leyes yo de hecho
presido la comisión de libertad de
Justicia interior que es la comisión de
mayor carga legislativa de todo el
parlamento europeo de la que es miembro
distinguida
además de vicepresidenta de la comisión
por ejemplo hacemos leyes aquí ahora
sucede que existen otros formatos de
actividad algunos de los cuales se
cualifican bajo la rúbrica de diplomacia
parlamentaria es decir establecer
relaciones institucionales en
representación del parlamento europeo
que consiguientemente la ciudadanía
europea con otros ámbitos de integración
regional en el mundo particularmente con
asambleas parlamentarias Esa diplomacia
parlamentaria está estructurada y debe
ejercerse con transparencia y misiones
oficiales si alguien rompe las reglas
ASUME su responsabilidad individual por
tanto si alguien acepta algo parecido
a lo que se llama en América Latina es
decir una dádiva un soborno aceptando un
viaje pagado por alguna otra potencia
extranjera algún otro país que no sea la
propia institución europea ASUME su
responsabilidad y desde luego si no lo
transparenta si no lo comunica esa
responsabilidad puede ser
responsabilidad penal cuando estoy
hablando de responsabilidades
individuales esto es importante decirlo
porque da la impresión y creo que he
tenido que salir al paso más de una vez
de esa de esa pendiente en la discusión
de que el parlamento europeo debiera de
sentirse culpable porque en un
parlamento de 700 miembros una sola
persona que en estos momentos es miembro
del parlamento europeo haya sido
detenida y está siendo investigada
penalmente Es cierto que la sospecha por
extensión ha tocado alguna otra persona
pero una sola persona miembro del
parlamento europeo en estos momentos
está en estos momentos Privada de
Libertad bajo investigación judicial
penal una sola persona de 700 y la
responsabilidad es toda suya no es del
parlamento europeo que falló no es del
parlamento europeo que es corrompible no
es del parlamento europeo que no ha
vigilado lo bastante que no nos los
diplomáticos extranjeros porque sería
inasumible llegar a la conclusión de que
no podemos tener interlocución con
diplomáticos extranjeros no sé que nos
vayan a corromper y no sea que los
corrompamos esta premisa es
absolutamente inaceptable la
comunicación institucional con
diplomáticos extranjeros es
perfectamente regular y perfectamente
habitual y perfectamente normal y
honorable en la medida en que trabajes
sobre los asuntos de competencia de este
parlamento europeo si alguien se desliza
por la pendiente de la corrupción es su
responsabilidad estrictamente individual
que el trabajo habitual es muy estricto
es muy serio Y si ha habido cosas que se
pueden ajustar y sin el registro de
transparencia o en las puertas
giratorias podemos trabajar mejor
hagámoslo y desde luego se puede hacer
tanto en asuntos constitucionales en
libertades civiles seguro que también
porque alguna cosa nos tocará y desde
luego en las comisión Inge estamos
hablando de las enmiendas ahora mismo y
creo que hay Tenemos también posibilidad
de evitar injerencia extranjera y
cooptación
de élites pues para Para mermar nuestras
capacidades geopolíticas o
geocomerciales que son una cosa bastante
paralela
nos queda muy poco tiempo como última
pregunta habéis hablado de la
honorabilidad de todos los miembros de
esta cámara a pesar de este caso de
corrupción pero tenéis consecuencias en
las próximas elecciones europeas que son
en mayo de 2024 parece que está aquí al
lado Juan Fernando ningún contexto
electoral es sencillo Tengo experiencia
como la tiene ahí tenemos hemos
sobrevivido a muchos procesos
electorales en nuestras vidas y sabemos
que efectivamente cuando nos aproximamos
a un momento caliente electoral todo se
pone cuesta arriba y te puede pasar
cualquier cosa y efectivamente cualquier
moneda que pueda ser de circulación para
hacer daño al adversario se utilizará
antes que estar prevenidos y sin duda
ninguna pero no es la primera vez que se
intenta infamar la acción parlamentaria
y al parlamento europeo en elecciones
europeas cuando no es una cosa es otra
cuando no es que el parlamento europeo
tienes casa visibilidad y que es un
cementerio de elefantes y que aquí no
existe tampoco una función reconocible
por la ciudadanía a veces son incluso
acusaciones con respecto de la doble
sede con respecto de la trashumancia
entre estrasburgo y Bruselas o con
respecto de la oficina parlamentaria que
mantiene los parlamentos europeos toda
perfectamente regulada toda
perfectamente transparente y por tanto
obediente a los reglamentos y a las
instituciones del derecho europeo Sí
nosotros será fácil y seguramente esto
esto habrá que explicarlo Pero creo que
es nuestro deber explicarlo e Insisto
que yo me siento en la obligación de
defender la honorabilidad y la
reputación del parlamento europeo como
parlamento legislador el único
parlamento supraestatal legislativo
directamente electivo del mundo y no es
aceptable que una sola persona que ASUME
su responsabilidades individuales infame
Al conjunto de la institución y no
debiéramos deslizarnos por esa pendiente
porque no solamente sería Injusto sino
contraproducente
estoy mirando nuestra resolución sobre
este tema de Qatar y una vez que se
conozcan los resultados de las
investigaciones penales vamos a crear
una comisión de investigación una
comisión especial además de algunas
otras cosas que aparecen aquí
sobre transparencia y puertas giratorias
si nos da tiempo yo creo que vamos a ir
con los trabajos bien hechos y creo que
vamos a ir con toda la transparencia
acerca de lo que ha ocurrido tenemos que
aprender de esta lección para intentar
minimizar el riesgo en la manera posible
porque siempre puede haber alguien que
quiera ser corrompido pero
concuerdo con Juan Fernando En que si
nos da tiempo haremos bien las cosas y
nos presentaremos pues ante los
ciudadanos tal y como somos Gracias
Maite Juan Fernando Lamentablemente Nos
quedamos sin tiempo a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
Europa hoy Gracias por ver trans 24 en
español
[Música]